It's fan appreciation month at Screen Junkies
and to reward our awesome fans
we're making the honest trailers that you voted for.
Here's the honest trailer you voted number one
for some reason.
From the studio that brought you the Dreamworks face
comes the animated feature that
revolutionized kids movies "Better out than
in I always say" by adding 90 minutes of
non-stop in jokes "Do you know the muffin man?
The muffin man? The muffin man." Shrek
Meet Shrek; an ogre who used to sound just
like Chris Farly. "Help! A big,
stupid, stinky, smelly, ugly ogre!." But when Chris
passed away he transformed into an ogre
who sounds just like that one voice
Mike Myers does
"Aargh, help, run" "Shut it!"
"I got a crap on deck that could choke a donkey." When his gas
base way of life is threatened, he'll set off on
a quest with: Donkey, a character who  is sadly
more famous and Eddie Murphy these days "I'm making waffles"
Fiona, a princess struggling with Bi-Ogre Disorder
and an entire kingdom's worth of
fairy tale characters that Disney had yet to
snatch up. "Eat me!" Together they'll prove that
nothing can overcome the power of true
love. Or more specifically the power of
having a dragon murder your enemies.
Wow they really just straight-up killed
him at the end. Wait, so who's running the
government now? You just started to coup.
Why are you dancing the swamp? Enjoy
early computer animation that looks just
as good as modern computer animation
that hasn't finished rendering. For a
story that parodies all the overused Disney tropes,
full of overused Disney tropes
like: The reluctant ugly hero who thinks
no one can love them,
the no-nonsense princess, the creepy
horny government official who wants to
be king and the lovable animal
sidekick. Hey if you can't beat them, join
them; while at the same time mercilessly
mocking them? *Donkey and Shrek laughing*
Settle in for a story with an important
lesson. Only ugly people can be together.
Wait, that can't be right. True love will
turn you into monster.
No that's not it either. Stick to your own kind?
Oo, no. Short people deserve ridicule? "Men of
Farquaad's stature are in short supply"
Uh, hey look guys are doing the
Macarena! Ha, references! So, come along for
the blockbuster hit that appealed to
adults and kids alike and won the
first academy award for best animated
feel all making fun of Disney's
obsession with franchising and
merchandising that spawn one great
sequel, too bad sequels, a spin off,
a Broadway musical, a ton of unfortunate
green merchandise, and that Smash Mouth
song has been stuck in your head since 2001
Starring, Chris Fartly
Beverly Hills Clop
Bi-Shrektual
Mini-Mean
Mother of Donkeys
and creepy animation errors
"I'm a delivery boy"
"swamp thing" what's up with all the shrek memes
i've been seeing let's see what
this is all about its Shrek
"I'm so happy, Shrek is love, Shrek is life"  Oh no no no Shrek is not
love Shrek is not life
oh who likes this drag be sure to
subscribe for more honest trailers
thanks to fans more es Connor I and
Renee G for helping to vote Shrek the
number one fan choice honest trailer and
thanks to EpicLLoyd of epic rap battles
for his epic smashmouth vocals and
thanks to all of you who helped make Fan
Appreciation Month great to check out
all of our fan voted honest trailers
including our epic collaboration with
Michael Bolton on Willy Wonka and the
Chocolate Factory
click the box on the left and if you
can't get enough kids movies
click the box to the right to see which
ones are actually worth watching
Hey now, you're all 'all stars'.
"This is my swamp"
"Not the buttons, not the gumdrop buttons"
"According to all known laws of aviation, wait, wrong movie."
"Ogres are like onions"
"It's all ogre now"
"Shrek is love, Shrek is life"